[Applause]
it's the night before Thanksgiving and
that means it's time for our annual
feast of some of our favorite characters
[Music]
each year based on opinion polls and
online voting the seven best late-night
characters have chosen and they share in
the honor of a great holiday feast as
you can see we have the manatee beloved
the cob
of course Frankenstein the masturbating
bear the giant ants the coked-up
werewolf shoe Vereen and oh well there
seems to be a little problem here I
apologize about this but there seems to
be a character who has crashed the party
that of course is the always
disappointing FedEx Pope arguably
arguably the worst character ever to
appear on late-night fedex poked yeah
yeah FedEx Pope I have to tell you
you're at the wrong dinner the meal for
our least favorite characters is
actually out in the hallway I'm sorry
you better just get going get out to the
hall I'm sorry FedEx Pope but that's
just the way it is
yeah you're just a guy
just a guy with a FedEx box on your head
that's really not a character sorry it's
just out in the hallway okay
okay we take a break all right back
horatio sanz